half of the gold that comes out of the
ground is used to make jewelry another
big chunk is used to make gold bars and
coins we've been using gold in this way
for thousands of years but recently
researchers have been experimenting with
using tiny amounts of gold in technology
and medicine in the future you could be
drinking water cleaned by brain heating
your home with solar cells that contain
gold or taking gold medicines gold makes
good watches rings and coins because
it's inert it doesn't really react with
oxygen so it stays looking nice and
shiny it's actually a pretty boring
metal from a chemistry point of view
bums
zoom into the nanoscale and gold gets
more interesting this gold nanoparticle
is a size of a virus at this scale it's
easy to manipulate and harness the
surface properties of gold for example
molecules like drugs can be attached to
the surface with the help of sulfur
atoms which can form covalent bonds with
gold the gold can then carry these drugs
to where they're needed in the body
inert gold is a good delivery vehicle
because it doesn't react with other
molecules in the body let's zoom in a
bit more at this scale gold
nanoparticles can be used to exploit a
special interaction between light and
matter because gold is a metal some of
its electrons are free to move around if
just the right wavelength of light is
used these electrons can be made to
oscillate all at the same frequency this
special property is called surface
plasmon resonance and it could be used
to turn gold nanoparticles into very
precise cancer killers these rod shaped
nanoparticles have antibodies attached
to their surface that allow them to bind
only to tumor cells and not healthy
cells once enough of them have
accumulated in the tumor
infrared light is used to make their
electrons oscillate
the energy from these oscillations
spreads to the surrounding area as heat
and the sudden temperature increase
kills the cancer cells but that's not
all they can do gold nanoparticles of
slightly different sizes absorb slightly
different wavelengths of light
so by gathering together different sizes
of nanoparticles it should be possible
to make solar cells that can absorb more
sunlight scientists are working on this
as one way to enhance the efficiency of
solar cells at the very smallest scale
Gold gets even weird
the proportion of surface atoms
increases and electronic and structural
properties of gold change and this gets
chemists interested because now gold can
react with stuff in fact tiny pieces of
gold turn out to be good catalysts for
example clusters of just 10 or so atoms
can turn carbon monoxide into carbon
dioxide just like platinum does in the
catalytic converter in your car
scientists would like to harness this
catalytic activity to find greener ways
to make industrially important chemicals
like hydrogen peroxide or to help purify
water by breaking down organic
contaminants Gold catalysts could also
be used to improve the performance of
fuel cells or to make better breathing
apparatus for firefighters
big lumps of gold have always been
valuable now that scientists are
unlocking the potential of gold
nanoparticles sprinklings of gold dust
are bringing some of gold's magic to
medicine and technology
you